do an excellent I would imagine that you
you get I would imagine the superhero
genre is something that you've seen or
been looking at from afar what was it
about venom and this character that said
I want to I want to enter the Marvel
Universe and I want to I want to play in
this world I've been watching some of
these movies not necessarily that it's a
Marvel movie but my guardians of the
galaxy and I think that Robert Downey
jr. is any you're like man they look
like they're I'm fun hmm interesting
like they look like they're they're
having fun and they're believing where
they are I'd like to try doing that that
seems like a fun interesting challenge
to take on and and then when this came
along I thought I'd really like to do it
with Tom Hardy right now I'm assuming
that tom was a yeah he was already yeah
doing this thing what is it like as an
actor though for you because you have
chosen such diverse roles and you've
been so fortunate with your with the
work to sign on to something like this
knowing you're gonna have to sign like a
multi-picture deal because that's what
comes with all of these properties um
you know I was talking to a friend of
mine who's a character actor and I was
we were talking about I'm working in
these worlds and playing these parts and
he was like god I just I love I love
this world because it's such an amazing
place to play roles that you would never
really get to there's so much meat for a
character actor because of this kind of
because anything is possible in these
universes and so you can go places and
do things and say things that you just
aren't normally allowed to and like you
know realistic human terrain and and
thinking about it like that it seems
like it opens up infinite possibility
and if you have a cast that you love
working within a crew that you love
working with it can be a really fertile
ground to keep returning to there is a
great scene in this film or Tom jumps in
a fish tank in a lobster tank which I
guess he decided to do the day before
and what is it like working with an
actor because
goes for it in this movie what is it
like working with someone who is just
fearless and willing to do anything for
the role it's super fun cuz you wind up
in all kinds of situations that you
wouldn't have imagined you know we would
come up with things that weren't
scripted and all of a sudden you're just
taking any sort of like nonlinear leaps
places and then it's really fun because
then you're you're truly improvising not
only the the the particulars of what
you're saying to each other but the
scenario that you're in and so it feels
like it's almost like flying you're just
like you're just taking these you don't
know exactly where you just were and you
don't know exactly where you're going
but you like you're in it together